peloton talking to you the indoor
exercise bike company released a new
holiday commercial that's caused an
uproar on social media
here's a look first ride I'm excited
let's do this
now some people on social media accused
the out of promoting an unhealthy
marriage dynamic and peddling negative
body images other users online were
unfazed by this commercial peloton did
not return our request for comment but
told the New York Times they stand by
the ad if I was peloton I would not get
engaged in this this seems much ado
about nothing if the if the guy I really
do believe this Tony if the guys had
given a bike to his wife and she was
overweight
we'd be complaining about that so just
because she's healthy doesn't mean that
it's an insult to her or that they're
questioning her body image I just think
it's really done I just it's a little
awkward for any husband for any man to
be giving a woman exercise equipment a
very clear message
I disagree you disagree I disagree
because I would like you if I was your
wife to give me the peloton treadmill I
hope my children are listening but why
is that an insult to say to say I'm
giving you this to help you because you
want to be saying I love you the way you
are they should have shown a little
cutaway word like that on the Christmas
list people like to stay in shape - I
just think it's crazy they do well
listen we're all talking about it the
stock fell yesterday quite a bit but
Kemper airily crashing these are their
exercise trends come and go you know so
we know Katy will not be getting an
exercise bike I heard say she already
has a peloton and I said that's gonna
become a coatrack Juiz right but she's
using it that's not insulting it's an
expensive nice bike I think it's a nice
gift if your husband gives it to him
it's Christmas list all right all right
there we go